hey y'all it's andrew koch here and this
title tuesday video
we're not going to be going over this
week's data set instead i was
looking over the titaverse blog and saw
that there were
a few updates on the tidy models package
and i thought it'd be fun to kind of
just um
investigate what they're doing in their
changes
and see how it can apply to our usual
workflow
so one of the main changes that they
made were the parallel processing with
tune
and the sparse data structures and tidy
models so with the sparse data
structures and tidy models
essentially they're going to offer um
different data structures that'll
basically optimize the way
our models will fit and what this really
means is
ideally it should be fitting um faster
since it can handle like sparse matrices
instead of your
traditional data frames so i was looking
over
uh what julia silgi's was doing and she
showed me her example
i thought it'd be interesting to do uh
to basically apply it to
my own data set and see if it actually
works and maybe kind of analyze what uh
what's going on and then um they
actually made a
change to the uh was it the uh
tune package which basically enables
parallel processing
so if you have worked with tidy models
and also worked with parallel processing
you'd
basically know that using parallel
processing
comes with a ton of headaches for me
whenever i would do some parallel
processing it would basically
not allow me to do anything else after i
finish the tuning
so how i would basically do it was i
would
create a separate script purely for
tuning with the tuning grid
and then apply the parallel processing
export that model and put it back into
my
analysis but what they essentially did
was
allow for different ways that
parallelize your tuning
so one of the problems was basically
you're working with re-samples
so with your k-folds cross-validation
data set and also your recipes
and they caused a lot of issues but
apparently they fixed that
so i think that'd be kind of cool to
show you how
parallel processing really works and how
how much better it is um
when you're using it for your own
training times um
in general basically you just have to
enable parallel processing
there's two options um basically using
the everything
and then resamples so with parallel
ovary samples it would essentially just
apply the preprocessing once and then go
through the resamples and fitting in
parallel
with everything it would do both the uh
resampling
and also the pre-processing so i thought
that'd be kind of cool to do an example
and kind of show you what i found
in my own data sets i'm not actually
going to type all this code out
i've already typed it in and there's not
a lot of code anyways
so i figured that you'd be better just
kind of read over my notebook or my
little our markdown document
and see what i did so i basically loaded
in
the titeverse tidy models tidy text
some text recipes and themis um these
are all just kind of like
text text and machine learning packages
and also class balancing stuff
so i read in my harry potter text csv
i essentially uh summarized it by each
character
um and then i basically uh combined all
of the characters text
into one single um value and then i
uh rebalanced the entire data set so it
would be um
balanced towards the um house because we
know from our
um previous um our previous uh
things uh that we have some imbalanced
data sets
uh so i just did that where we have our
house
rebalanced so it'll be equal for
everything just for sandy um
and so it'd be a little bit faster
usually i would just do it by
a defined length of text but for this
example i figured it'd be kind of easier
to run
all these models at once um to assess
the training times
so i did that where i basically
rebalanced the data set
i set my c created my generic train and
test splits
made a k-folds data and then i actually
went into what
julia cilia was doing and highlighting
uh the first thing which was
the um what was it which was the
sparse data structures with tidy models
so when i
actually was doing some nlp work um i
guess i guess a year
right out a year ago um i was basically
doing it as i kind of got a naive way
how she was doing it where essentially i
was counting um i was computing
um my dictionary of words i wanted to
use using the tf idf algorithm
and then um basically using that as a
dictionary
filtering it out so then i could
basically count
out um how many words each character was
saying
uh for each for each uh
sample so for this i'm essentially just
uh creating a matrix
but i actually didn't convert it to a
matrix instead i just uh used it as
essentially
a traditional data frame where each
column represented a certain word that
was in my
tfidf algorithm so as you can see these
words
seem pretty um seem to make a decent
amount of sense most of them are names
which may cause probably some uh data
leakage because if someone's saying like
direct uh draco they're probably uh
either a gryffindor or slytherin etc
but for this example um i didn't like
remove any uh
names like i did in my original project
so i basically created a document term
matrix um but i didn't convert it to
anything
so you see it's pretty sparse there's a
bunch of zeros
um and then there's occasionally a few
eights and ones etc
so i did that i created my k-folds data
set with this like naive matrix
and then i went on to do um your generic
pre-processing what you really should be
doing which
where we're basically just doing some
tokenization removing our stop words
um creating a token filter so we're
saying like max tokens is 75
and then we're computing the tfidf score
i also wanted to highlight um some ways
you can actually
speed up your model training times is to
kind of look at
where your pre-processing is at and
starting to remove
expensive pre-processing so i added step
iso map which is essentially like a
clustering
um algorithm i think or it'll basically
um
kind of combine these predictors into a
few terms
um this is pretty expensive um but
honestly both
um iso map and also like the
tokenization part
is pretty expensive where we're
basically trying to do all these counts
every time
um it's very uh expensive
computationally
compared to this method where i'm
essentially pre-calculating
all of the um bag of words and tokens
and then i'm just saying split it up in
two days that don't do anything else and
just
train the model and run so what i would
expect is actually this to be slightly
faster um but um and
realistically if you want to do other
pre-processing that's a little bit more
complicated so if you want to do
um more or stop word removal
more token filtering maybe you want to
do like a topic modeling and stuff like
that or use embeddings
it might be easier um just visually to
see this
and when you're actually doing a model
in production and you want some
type of like stored um feature list
this way was probably the best better
way to do it
so one of my next um
tips which is pretty pretty um
uh it most people would know what to do
for this but
when you're trying out models definitely
try a simpler model
so for in this case i actually choose a
elastic net model which is like a
combination of
original lasso regression where i can
penalize
penal uh terms to be zero
but also i can just shrink them so it'll
be approaching zero and not actually
fully eliminate them one thing i would
also say is
uh using a complex model like xgboost is
actually pretty terrible
for a lot of nlp problems especially
multi-class
nlp problems because xgb boost just does
not really work
great with multi-class classification it
was in my own
work that i've done so that's just an
example of a very complex model where
i was going to start out modeling a nlp
project i would definitely not start
with xgboose
i would definitely probably stick with
an elastic model or even a k nearest
neighbor model
so i also want to show you um some more
efficient ways that
you know try out different parameters so
generally
i will always use grid regular but
there's also grid max entropy which will
basically
use different combinations of parameters
in a more efficient manner so if i
actually compare
the elastic grid and the elastic entropy
grid we can see that
for the elastic grid it's doing it more
in sequential order right it's saying
like
yeah we want a penalty of 0.1 you know
etc
he goes up with all the combinations of
mixture whereas elastic
entropy is kind of just doing kind of
the middle ground where it's basically
using a diverse pairing of parameters
that aren't in the sequential order so
it's covering more distance with
less sets of parameters which would
generally just show you uh
if you're if you're not sure how much
you should penalize and stuff like that
um you could uh get better results or at
least faster training times
using a different grid additionally i've
already gone
over this too in some past videos but um
just applying some
actual filterings to your grids will
make more sense
even though tidy models will give you a
pretty good default
list of parameters um they will give you
some weird ones where
if i have an xg boost model and i
basically know that
i won't only need one tree it seems
pretty pointless to include
just one tree i would probably use a
decent amount of trees
same with tree depth i wouldn't expect
you know me only using
one a decision decision tree with one uh
with a depth of one
right because that's just a a generic
decision tree
so i could filter that out and i'll kind
of remove some of that garbage
then we can compare the actually boost
um grid with the xg boost entropy grid
and we can see that for the trees it's
doing essentially one
one thousand two thousand one eight
fifteen
whereas the the entropy or max entropy
is showing a more diverse
list of trees with a more diverse list
of tree depths so
in this case it's using a lot of trees
right but it's also
using um a pretty deep
depth for the trees and sometimes i'll
use less trees
but with a shorter depth whereas this
one's kind of doing a middle ground of
the of all of it where i think like say
1008
and then 2008 and eight might not be
a great informative primer set to use
because they might be
basically the same thing okay so we can
see how
i guess entropy grid can do pretty well
um with doing more efficient especially
if you're maybe at a time crunch where
uh we want a model i'm out there for a
meeting
we want to assess the results but um i
um
we also wanted to be as accurate as
possible so instead of doing grid
regular you might do grid max entropy so
you can kind of get a better
baseline of what you're trying to assess
okay and now i actually created a a uh
i started tuning the models so one of
the ways to actually apply
this different data frame type or
basically create a matrix instead of a
traditional table
is you basically use hard hat and then
you say default recipe blueprint
composition equals dgc matrix i'm sure
there's going to be more compositions or
more
data types in the future but in the
example they just use
a document matrix um i basically assign
that into the recipe
on basis saying like i want you to
tokenize all these words
and then i want to you want you to
convert it to a matrix
then basically two in the models and uh
oops i tuned the models and collected
the results so i
i created a beginning time tuned it and
then i
record the end time and now and then i'm
gonna put them basically
together into a single table and we'll
see at the rest of the
at the end of the analysis
so i also want to do more i want to show
the more expensive preprocessing
so basically just add in the expensive
pre-processing recipe
same sparse document term matrix
tune it collect the results and we can
see it's basically calculating all these
things
i'm creating the uh i guess clustering
or embedding
and it's doing that multiple times for
each resample
so you can see how that's a lot of work
and we could probably expect that it'll
probably take a little bit longer to
train
than our other baseline recipe model
and then finally i also showed a
different way to tune your model
or essentially you don't give it a grid
instead you use a bayesian approach
so a tune based what's kind of cool
about it is you don't give it a actual
um grid a parameter grid instead you
kind of just let it
run and it'll basically um
try to optimize a metric it'll um
first give you a one set of parameters
train it then i'll create another set of
parameters that'll be different
you know i basically have an expectation
of it improving
so if the model doesn't improve with the
re-samples it'll basically stop training
and you can actually set that um at
threshold so if
on one hand if you want to be a little
bit more um cautious about it
you might set the number of approvals to
a higher number so um you want to make
sure you're not just at a local minimum
and you're
actually at the global minimum or global
maximum for
depending i guess how you would refer to
that metric
so you can do a decent amount of fine
tuning for how long you want it to run
and i think there are some defaults to
it with like the number of iterations or
number of primers i'll check
uh i think it might be 30 but you can
definitely change that
if you're using like a smaller model
like a lasso model where you essentially
have one parameter
but it's always something to keep in
mind i think one good use case with
a bezing approach is if you're say at
home
um you're going to go to bed you don't
really know what primers you want to
choose
but uh you want to tune it it doesn't
really matter when it finishes as long
as you have to give it a decent
time so you could run like a tuned bass
um instead of your generic tune grid and
let it run
overnight you wake up and you have a
fully tuned model with some results of
like
what your um your bayesian approach was
doing you can kind of see the actual
route it was taking or the number of
iterations it took with the improvements
of
what score you're trying to optimize and
you can also specify what
uh metric you want to so i ran that
i basically said that if it doesn't
improve after three iterations or three
um pairings uh you can stop so you can
see it running
saw that there wasn't really any change
we see that it's like 0.883
879 879 so basically stopped it says no
improvements after three iterations
returning the current results and we can
see the different parameter sets it was
chain
uh trying this first prime set was point
zero zero zero two five six
so not a huge penalty
uh you can see it change doing a
different one you can see it doing
another different one
so you can see it's kind of interesting
how how it's just choosing its
parameters
i'm not sure if it's uh i think it might
be a gaussian
process because it says gaussian but it
i wonder if there's a an
option to choose like some different
type of process so you could say like
i want to try this this set of
parameters start at the bottom
start at the top of the list go down and
see how much it improves
etc i think that would be an interesting
um choice to
interesting uh implementation in this
in this function but i'm not sure really
how that under underlying
functions work in toon bays but it'd be
interesting to see
what they start building upon it and
then lastly i want to show you
um probably the thing that is used the
most is the do parallel
i use do parallel sometimes i'll use
future map
which is like the map of where you can
do parallel processing
using mapping functions uh i think that
uh
future map uses the new future or the
future package
but when i do modeling i just have
always done do parallel just because
um there's more documentation on it at
least for a modeling standpoint
but i do like using the uh future and
future map package
so i actually did this um it's the same
thing adding actually parallel
processing to your training process
is very easy um again you just
give it a model control or a control
grid so if it's a tuned grid it'd be
control grid
if it's fit resamples i think it's like
um
control resamples but the same thing um
they have the same options they're just
for different
um functions and they all correspond
with each other
so the first thing that i added was
allow parallel so i want to allow
parallel
equals true and then you have another
option that they just added
which you can do either everything or
resamples
in this case since i was thinking that
um we're always gonna be using the
um the recipe package to basically uh
tokenize
each free sample i figured we want to
basically paralyze
the both the resampling and the
pre-processing
however if you don't really need to do
that pre-processing
of like tokenization and maybe it's just
like a generic center and scale
or something like that you might not
even need to use everything in that case
you probably do resamples
if you don't know i believe you can just
leave it blank i'll basically decide for
you
um oh i also forgot that um to actually
register
your um parallel processing on your in
on your workspace
you just do do parallel make psoc
cluster
i said four because i have four physical
cores on my computer
and then you register your your parallel
workers
you're also supposed to like stop the
process um but in this case uh i'm just
not gonna do it right now
but i think it's like a stop um
stop implicit cluster yeah so if you
stop and plays a cluster
and then you would stop that parallel
processing
and then finally i actually just plotted
out the train times
just so we can evaluate you know what
was uh what were the actual results and
then we can kind of see
um then i can kind of explain what was
actually going on
as you can see with bays the base um
tuning
definitely lasts the longest but this is
highly tunable
so it could i could just set it for was
like two iterations
it'd probably be a little bit faster but
with toon bays it's
it's so much faster to just like start
training
than to actually determine your
parameter grids and it's highly
customizable
whereas with tune grid if you already
passed your global minimum
our your global your global maximum for
your parameters
it'll still keep going through the
entire primer set and that can be pretty
annoying
so it has its trade-offs but i think
tune-based is definitely still a thing
that you should
keep in mind when you're training up
your models as for our second
um longest training time we can see that
our expensive one
took the second longest but what's odd
about this is with compared to
the the traditional route where you use
the recipe or use the
document term matrix they're actually
very similar so the expresso one is
slightly faster but not at a point where
i would say
it's not worth doing um and then with
the naive the naive is actually faster
than
basically all the rest of the models and
i think the main reason why
it's faster is because i pre-computed
the tf idf score
so essentially this isn't necessarily a
fair comparison
um but i just thought it was interesting
especially since julia silly did show
the example of doing the tf idf
pre-processing
and pre-computing it so i would have
expected the naive
a way to do it where you just create the
counts already and then you assess it
later
it could be a little bit slower but
maybe i'm doing something wrong it's
always something to consider where
maybe sometimes the naive route will be
easier and live faster
with that being said um we can see that
the parallel processing
still beat the naive um
the naive way to do it so even with
parallel
with with parallel processing and doing
all that computational expensive
pre-processing
with the um recounting of the the tfidf
score
we can beat this naive fork naive uh not
not e4s
it's naive processing where we already
pre-computed it
so this kind of shows just how fast
parallel processing is
uh which makes sense because parallel
processing you're essentially using like
four times the competing power
um when doing it but we can see it here
oh even
when we have these like pre-configured
um word counts
parallel processing will still beat it
most of the time
so i know this is a pretty quick video
um
i i wanted to make this video piece i
thought it was pretty interesting and i
just saw it today
so i wanted to create a quick video
about just how to speed up your
model training time uh definitely
something that's pretty interesting and
i'm pretty
i'm stoked to see what's what's coming
up next with the tiny models
with that being said i'll see you guys
next week and teddy on